for me the happiness part is the only
part
i was happy as [ __ ] in this store down
there in 2001 where nobody in the world
knew who the [ __ ] i was i was as happy
21 years ago in this building and it
wasn't even this building this was built
later it was a little building down
there facing that street right down
there
21 years ago as i am this exact second
not a dollar not a fan not a nothing
nothing that has happened to me publicly
in the last 20 years has added a single
ounce of happiness
the process is my happiness
and there's no way to get to a great
place without it you'll just burn out
when it comes to content creation for
that so i always kind of want to have my
own thing on the side i've been in the
jewelry industry and finance so um when
it comes to doing your own content
creation i know you've been kind of
asked this before but is it better
because i have so many interests i've
got the sneakers i've got the jewelry
the finances the content creation how do
you kind of tailor that like would you
subdivide your tick tock or would you
you could i mean well together the
answer the answers of the past are a
little bit
void yeah because tick tock
really has tripled down on what i've
always believed which is it's not about
your followers it's about the content
yeah so i believed it when it was more
about the followers and the followers
would see it and i was very empathetic
like if you're into business but i'm
making a jets post and you're a die-hard
dolphins fan or don't care about
football well that's not going to hit
and i was never worried about that
because i always felt that people over
analyzed every single piece of content
but now where we're at with the
tick-tockification of social it's about
the content anyway for example everybody
here can start a brand new tick tock
account have no followers
and that post can get 8 000 views and
the next one can get 200 if you had 10
000 followers so it's now more than ever
about the content anyway thus rendering
all of us being able to post about what
we want at all times without hurting
everyone has always worried that this is
going to hurt me it's going to [ __ ] up
the algorithm i'm not going to get as
many views and likes it's just not the
reality of how social works anymore so
combining like sneakers and jewelry is
fine huge yeah yeah thank you
what's going on uh my name is ian
lipkowski
on most of my socials i'm kowski
orkowski.ed
just wanna also say first time we met
was 2017 it was at a shoe release in new
york city didn't realize it was
happening i was at work i sprinted out
of work to come down there and meet you
um when i met you that day i said my
favorite quote was that you're gonna die
and i was strategizing how to like
become uh bigger and build myself so i
now own that you're going to die fly
strategizing in new york that's awesome
by the way on that i apologize because i
think this will bring value to people we
were talking about it in the corner over
there like affinity like
right now so much of what nft land was
about for the last year was flipping i
could make money i could give a [ __ ] if
it was an ape or a doodle or a v friend
or like it was just like where can i
make a buck
that story really is important because
the reason you'll never sell that is it
means something to you the same reason i
like collecting occasionally a batman
thing because batman means a lot to me
it was one of the things i like learned
america through or scooby-doo i
mentioned a lot of times of buying and
if that's on purpose because that's
meant something to me and i think it's a
really important thing like
that is the journey that i'm most on how
do i get
me included me excluded right there's
obviously me in that story but
what what does the video game look like
that has nothing to do with me that gets
people to care about gracious grizzly at
scale go ahead
uh other question is i have my own brand
now it's called alien inks uh i'm
wearing it right now it's aliens.com
it's inks inks like pennings um i'm
basically just doing everything i can to
do
content creation but these designs are
pretty intricate they take a lot of time
so my time is split between doing the
art uh posting the art
just being on different types of socials
trying to do videos trying to document
everything yes um things are kind of
starting to pick up now so i just
recently i got into a cafe they're gonna
do my they're actually displaying my art
i had a friend from high school who does
singing now she wore a dress that i made
during a concert so that's really cool
um you know a few people starting to buy
it i have like an nft collection that's
on my twitter
the nft collection is kind of to
build the idea of different characters
that are going to exist within the
alienx world but then also give back
like discounts like a percentage of
people who buy things from the website
so it has that kind of like instant
utility
um i don't know if i have a question to
ask you specifically but just like
hearing everything like i'm thinking
you're just gonna be like just keep
going do more and more and more and more
um maybe that's it but it's there any
other no it's always that like yes of
course
of course there is how you do forever
is variable difference like hey i want
to be a great basketball player we'll
practice every day but if you're not
practicing efficiently or smartly you
can only maximize your talent so much
and you only have so many talents
like you could say to somebody play
basketball every day there's a very good
chance that that person isn't built to
be a professional basketball player i
think people really struggle with
understanding the difference between
maximizing their upside against
the delusion of their ambition
right like you like that one kid
like you know when people like gary i'm
gonna
when 29 year olds come up to me like
gary i'm gonna be like you as an
entrepreneur and i get three seconds of
context
before the third second's done i say to
myself unlikely not because i'm being
egotistical or competitive it's that by
the time i was 29 i did business 24
hours a day every day for 24 years
for real
actually
right like this store
like like when everyone's like gary i've
been doing this for a year i'm like i
did a year's worth of wine library tv
after i was 30. 15 years of wine
education and selling
to just get to a minimum base of getting
30 comments per like people are so
delusional of what it takes to succeed
and and and so
yes of course it's that but the question
becomes getting a discount from the
website
is not interesting if you don't want
anything from the website right
and so the question becomes how can
someone get it done what gets people to
care
and so
yeah i mean i think it is that i always
believe it's content creation content
creation is storytelling it's awareness
it's how you connect but obviously some
people are better at storytelling than
others the question for everybody that's
trying to do their own [ __ ]
is
are you realistic with your capability
and are you happy about that that
doesn't mean don't believe in yourself
and don't cap out but i think where
people really get hurt genuinely get
hurt is
they have
expectations that are so unrealistic
that it makes them deviate from the
enjoyment of why they're doing it
and um and i'm always scared to be
compared to when it's in business
compare
being compared to and playing pickleball
i feel good about many of you can be
better being compete you know compared
to in
a million things i feel comfortable i
get very uncomfortable when people want
to compare themselves to me
in entrepreneurship because i've been
doing it for so long and i'm really
really really good at it
like i you know and you know i just i
think that we all have to be self-aware
and i think
being self-aware and realistic while
pushing the ambition
and committing to a decade worth of
ungodly amounts of work if you want
something special
without even thinking about how far
along am i is not something most people
are comfortable with
like like for anyone who's starting a
dead scratch and has nobody give a [ __ ]
about anything alien inc
10 years
15 hours a day 12 hours a day 10 hours a
day 8 hours a day
minimum
10 years
don't even look up to see how you're
doing is not something people want to
sign up for
one thing i'll say is i'm already happy
that uh i even got my friend to do it at
the concert i'm happy people are seeing
it here so i may not beat you as an
entrepreneur but i may go hand in hand
on the happiness because i'm happy as
far as that is the best
that's the best
that
that that makes me emotional in the best
way that is the purpose of every way i'm
trying to communicate which is unless
you are completely upset for me
on the
for me the happiness part is the only
part
i was happy as [ __ ] in this store down
there in 2001 where nobody in the world
knew who the [ __ ] i was i was as happy
21 years ago in this building and it
wasn't even this building this was built
later it was a little building down
there facing that street right down
there
21 years ago as i am this exact second
not a dollar not a fan not a nothing
nothing that has happened to me publicly
in the last 20 years has added a single
ounce of happiness
the process is my happiness
and there's no way to get to a great
place without it you'll just burn out i
think i have the uh the honor of saying
i think i've consumed more of your
content than anyone in here for sure one
baby on the planet because they've been
watching since episode one of the
thunder show wow around here maybe
it's amazing thank you
thank you um
but i wanted to know and i'm not talking
i'm not going to ask you to talk about
like
which
10k pmp project is your favorite or
anything like that but just thinking
about like when i got i'm in tech that's
what i do for a living it was so [ __ ]
painful to get a metamask wallet to put
money yeah the whole onboarding process
is
impossible even to like move my
token from my ledger so hard burner
wallet
yes so in your mind
what and who
in web 3
were talking deep by nfts
yeah anything i got you who's doing the
coolest most innovative stuff that
excites you the most so couple questions
when did you get into tech
like professed professionally 20 years
ago
in 2002 yeah cool so
when i launched winelibrary.com in 1996
here
every person that walked through the
store that i just mentioned the original
store down there
we asked them for their email
more than half i did i asked them for
their email
more than half of them
more than half had no idea what email
was
and
the other
10 20
that did
half of them told me their email was aol
yahoo.com
[Applause]
this store really exploded in 1998 when
i came on full time and started running
new york times ads
and half
half of our business was people driving
from new york to here to buy wine here
and i would tell all of them i would say
you don't have to schlep from new york
you should go to winelibrary.com this
that almost all of them all of them
these are you know high net worth
educated wall street type characters
that were collecting high-end wine
almost all of them in 1998-99 said that
they didn't trust putting their credit
card into a computer
so 96 for me 96 to 2001
and really
96-2003 was this incredible seven year
journey of watching the world go from
completely dismissing web one and the
comforts of it to it beginning in 2003
to where we are today becoming the
foundation of our society
that is inevitably going to happen
the question is going to become to
answer your question
is the coolest stuff actually web 2.5
or is it web 3 because what i think is
that almost everybody
would give up
the ideology of web 3 complete control
of course because everybody loved total
defy until their [ __ ] was stolen and
then they were mad at open c me and coin
base but we're like you're totally in
control
we're not
i can't do anything
and so and so
people want
web 25 and if they want web 25 then it
opens up everybody then it opens up visa
then it opens up amex then it opens up
meta then it opens up google and apple
and so the question i think that's most
interesting in the next 36 months
is where is the world gonna land between
web 2 5 and web 3
because i think
people don't want
centralization in theory [ __ ] the
government everyone loves [ __ ] the
government until somebody comes to your
home with a gun and says get the [ __ ]
out of your house
like you're looking for the government
you know and so
you know everybody loves the wild wild
west until they're the one that gets
shot
so i think that
what i think is going to happen is the
world's going to be split up into web 2
5
aka
front-facing consumer interfaces that
are not challenging
where the complicated shit's happening
behind the scenes
but obviously the custodial then sits
with coinbase not with you right but
you're willing to give up that and
willing to give a piece of the
transaction action to not have your [ __ ]
stolen and then what i like is that the
people that want to be pure web3
like [ __ ] coinbase [ __ ] the system knock
yourself out you could have a metamask
you can have your seed phrase you can
and so i think that's what's gonna
happen and so the i think the coolest
[ __ ]
is going to be the company or three or
seven that build consumer interfaces
that are slick
somewhat appease the web 3 people like
very easy to like get off like you know
what i mean something that gives them
kind of like that in between but really
works for the masses here so shit's easy
you know and that's built like for
example to make it easier for like we're
spending so much time
on what are we gonna do on our dot com
and our app that allows you to get
verified for here
not have to touch your cold wallet not
like right even the fact that we made
everybody go with id here like we're
we're going to do it
bubble gum and tape when i want to
randomly do [ __ ] but we're within six
months of having that be seamless within
the app and puts you in a position to
not be vulnerable to take off cold
storage but you'll have to be in first
party data within
vfrs.com
web3 maxis don't want that cool how do
you offer that while you are willing to
put your information so it's a lot of
fun to think about web 25 to web 3.
but for me
this is just like i've seen this movie
before
i i was there i lived it it's how i
started my career
most people weren't
most people weren't of the age or were
not in
web 95 to 2000 so this is all kind of
feels so ridiculous because we were we
literally went into web 3 from a mature
web 2.
that's like a big drop off and that's
why we've had so many i mean this merge
this ethereum merge the amount of people
that are gonna get scammed
is gonna be extraordinary because it's
gonna be all in the air
people are gonna people are people fall
for the things that people fall for most
of the people most of the people that
were scammed
during the last six months were scammed
on things that triggered their emotional
trigger to be first to get the thing or
to get a deal that they couldn't get
otherwise and they were too quick to
connect and in the beginning of it
people didn't even realize that you
could connect and give access and be
stolen from but the last three four or
five months it's all been based on
emotional trick the scammers know your
trigger point there's a free v friend
series three drop go
i haven't said [ __ ] about it
i've never referenced it you see it on
twitter you're like [ __ ] boom boom and
you're out and that's and that's what's
happening and so
it's just gonna take an education cycle
it just is what it is
uh thank you for having us thanks for
being here um
i think the biggest thing i'll be
relatively selfish
please uh
i think i'm subjected to that saying
that like jack of jack of all trades
master done yeah i'm a damn good
personal trainer okay so like that's my
that's my bread and butter that's what
we keep doing that's what pays the bills
yes but
the two kind of conflicts that i have is
a that takes away from because i work
with clients like right six
matter when they want to see me that's
when they see me yes and i'm
always going to be you know
mercy to that but i have so many other
things i think
you don't i tried to do them all hold on
there's something really important there
which is
you're not always going to be at the
mercy of that if you're willing to not
make that maximize its economics or if
you're so damn good people will
compromise into yours meaning if you
decide
that you only work monday wednesday and
friday 6 a.m to noon
only so that you can really do your
other [ __ ] well then you could and if
you're so great you might lose harold
and susan but timmy and sally are right
behind them and you fill those slots and
you call it a day
people get confused because they think
everything is so extreme one or the
other
and they don't realize they can create
restrictions within the middle meaning i
just gave you the black and white way
that you can control a lot more of your
time as a personal trainer you just have
trainer hours
you're scared
properly not scared you're thinking
properly i don't i don't want to lose
these two people
but the reality is if you make those
restrictions
if you create enough of the content or
demand in another way somebody will take
up those slots and now you're six to
noon monday wednesday friday you could
just like re i mean i've watched a lot
of trainers
be scared shitless for that jump
and a lot of times when i talk to them
whether they're friends acquaintances or
just random dms i've stuff not only do i
tell a lot of them the advice of doing
that if they have this want i also tell
them to raise their costs in the same
time and the reality is there's a lot of
demand for for personal trainers
and so all of a sudden you wake up and
you're more in control of your schedule
and you're making 20 more per hour
against that schedule and now you're
[ __ ] rolling and to your credit by
the way part of i'm trying to do that to
an extent like i've been super hard on
ticked off the last five months and like
for anybody that doubts it i had
something over a million views like i
went from literally zero nobody on
instagram followed me that knew me like
these are all strangers like uk
germany's it's crazy um three pieces of
content a day every day of the week like
no matter what um so i'm trying to push
that so that i can fill some of my
well there's there's also a two point
where do you where do you live stanford
i work in westchester right so there's
also a 2.0 version of that which is you
run tick tock ads only
in that area so that the people that so
you've got a million views on that video
clearly that video resonates
take that video and run instagram
facebook and tick tock ads only within a
20-mile radius of your home where the
copy says if you're looking for training
email me here
so there's the first small business like
one guy oh like i haven't run out of my
life i respect the [ __ ] of that you know
like until eight years ago i'd never
done a push-up in my life like
you know like you know so so
so yeah i'm giving you i'm giving you
the black and white that will change
your life the number one thing in social
media that i'm most excited about now is
something i call brand performance you
put out organic to these algorithms all
the algorithms on every platform are
going to follow tick tock because it
works it works because it's more based
on merit we as humans who work hard and
want things to happen for us based on
our content
want the algorithm to give us as many
people to see it if we crush it i would
much rather every video i post
get
17 views
100 views but then if i really got it
give me 19 million if the world is like
keeps if the
humans keep telling you platform that
they still want this that this is a hit
it's not that extreme but as you know
tick tock is
the closest thing to that now meta is
going down that direction instagram's
gonna do that
i i think you're seeing it in youtube
shorts which is why i've been saying it
facebook fan pages why i'm bringing it
up they're starting to do it as well
so the model is put out as much as you
can different [ __ ] it hits now you know
that people resonate with it
now you take it back the original video
and you change the copy
so the original copy of whatever got a
million had copy now you slightly tweak
it and turn it into a right hook right
i've been actually i'll drop some alpha
here i am like
90 sure i'm gonna write jab jab jab left
hook
right because when i think about what
that book meant for so many people if i
can write wrote it 10 years ago if i can
write the updated version of it i think
it'd be value so i'm like the reason i'm
probably even just said it out loud is i
think i'm there and i've already started
like mapping it in my head
right
and so
i think that
i think
one of the things i'm going to talk
about in that book for sure is this
put it out organically it hits
take it back
add to the copy or slightly tweak the
copy to make it a transactional piece of
content now not just a brand piece of
content for you it's ps if you're
interested in training in the
westchester connecticut upper new york
area please email me info in my bio and
then run 500 worth of ads against that
it's gonna work because the creative's
already shown to you because the
algorithm now is not based on people
it's based on interest so you know the
ad is good
yeah i love that tonight really quick
youtube shorts do i just take my tick
tock that i create just throw it on
there
for
regulated organically on youtube it's
always preference that you can textually
make it for the platform because even if
you start that video it's like hey
youtube
just that already changes the time
temperature on the flip side we throw my
tick tocks onto my shorts like you only
have so many hours in the day you only
have so much time and effort and the
reality is is that
are you limiting some of the upside yes
but if you don't have time to make one
just for youtube shorts
it's just i the only reason i'm so
hesitant to say it that way is i know if
i open up that kimono everyone's just
gonna make one cup piece of content and
put it everywhere and that's not the way
you want to do it for the time being i
do think so on the flip side there's a
lot of team gary here
all of them are thinking in their head
how different something is working on
tik tok versus instagram like especially
this last couple weeks we're seeing
things where like we can get a million
views on instagram and the tick tock can
get like 30 000. these are extreme
differences and there has there's a lot
to do with it everybody always talks
about propaganda like tick tock knows
that you posted it on instagram all this
[ __ ]
there's always chance for certain little
things but it's more about
humans
tend to understand the spirit of it plus
platforms are different just i've always
said it you're the same person but when
you're in your tick tock versus when
you're in your instagram versus when
you're in your linkedin your entire
being is different no different
than a lot of scenarios all of you are
different in this setting right now than
you would be if you with your best
friends or at your favorites if i was at
a tailgate of the jets i will be at a
tailgate on monday with my closest
friends my energy is going to be
different than it is here i'm in a
different setting it's a different
context and that's how these platforms
work but you should take that mil that
one of the things that sid and i talk a
lot about is
bon jovi is still [ __ ] selling out
stadiums selling singing the same nine
[ __ ] songs
i i still haven't gotten there and i
might even push it harder just to make
it really a good part of jab jab jab
left hook because i don't even need to
test it i know the answer which is if i
just go back and repost because we do it
occasionally and repost the 30 most
successful posts i've had in my career
today nine years later four years later
they're gonna [ __ ] crush
that piece of content that you had get a
million you should milk the living [ __ ]
out of that what most people do is try
to find the next one what we don't do is
squeeze the [ __ ] out of the viral post
that one post you should get into shorts
you should set up your facebook fan page
because of it it should you should do it
three more times on instagram in stories
twitter this like it should be like
squeeze the [ __ ] out of that virality
i uh i'm heavy into the card game i love
it sports cards uh no training cards and
trading cards oh though yes i've brought
three one of ones yes with me and i'd
love to work out a trade with you if
you're up to okay what do you got i've
got the auto ninja auto ninja wow bubble
gum panda wow and the hollow
armadillo okay
i don't want to figure something out
what are you interested in i want a bf1
a bf1
so i think so
you can sit
i gotta think
um
let me let me tell you let me tell you
what my initial reaction is
solely you know and it's fun to like
talk this out so it's really fun to see
brandon in the background at the card
show which i saw a lot of you there and
when you watch me on trash talk
if you've paid close attention i know a
lot of you do and i think this will land
with a lot of you
i literally just go into that mindset
like at the card show
i was just a baseball card dealer like
the whole time and i think a lot of you
noticed that if you watch trash talk
like
yes there's a part of me that wants to
teach people that if somebody has
something for three dollars you should
offer a dollar because if you only have
eighty dollars and you're watching trash
talk to like make your life better like
you need those two dollars
but eighty percent of it is i just don't
know how not to be that human being when
i'm at a garage sale i don't care how
much money i have right now when i go to
garage sale i have a garage sale jersey
on
and if somebody wants five bucks for
something i want to offer 50 cents
so right now i'm in full
not like i want to do nice by you or
this is good for the brand or this could
be a good video i'm fully in like you
want to [ __ ] trade
and so
and so where my mind goes is
the vf1 value
is too low
in its truth
versus the cards value right now are
fair
if not potentially even slightly
elevated because it's hot
and so to me that's just going to be a
challenging trade to make
because i like legitimately no [ __ ]
the biggest problem i have right now is
i want to buy all the vf ones myself
but i don't think i can
because unlike the stock market where a
stock buyback is often looked as
confidence
i don't think our market is mature
enough yet maybe in six years i'll be
able to do that if there's another
window i think if i was to do that today
people are like oh gary's using his
money to inflate the floor price so
that's the only reason i've stayed away
because i have to be thoughtful of that
[ __ ]
but
i just the thought of trading a vf1 that
i have right now
is like the worst feeling and like i do
i want them all on the flip side the
ninja is a big [ __ ] card
the panda's a big card i'm i'm
incredibly open to the following you
should email me within the title
i want both the ninja and the panda what
do you want in return with a link to my
openc and that's how we can start it
i've been fortunate enough to
live in a few continents and i have been
in finance for the last 11 years
how should i make the next move i don't
know what the next move is whether it's
being comedian writing a book or
investing all my money on being friends
well the third one's clearly right
how should i find that inspiration which
i did find before different continents
right yeah and every time i move
continents like it was i was born in
india raised in australia moved to
united states every time it was a rough
ride yes right so let's say i make a
move to be friends one i don't want like
i'm scared of that roughness that's
tough at the same time that's also
different investing is not your behavior
meaning not like i i love the friends
because i'm in charge
like the biggest reason i don't like
buying other stuff is i'm not in charge
the reason i only buy crypto punks is
it's the only one that i know
that doesn't need anybody to do anything
it just is going to trade on history
whereas board ape and cool cats and
goblins and penguins and v friends it's
all required on us the operators
you know like
so
to me
going to a new country and establishing
yourself and living life
is a very different journey than being a
passive investor in something right um
i think the writing book and the comedy
stuff excited me a lot more than v
friends because that's you doing
something v friends is you making a
decision listen
i i would also counter my own talk and
tell you that so much of my wealth
creation was betting on other things you
know facebook and uber and snapchat and
like twitter and like i've done very
well in that when it's all said done i
will absolutely make more by what i
operated than by what i invested in but
i've won on both
i've lost in investing i've never lost
operating
and so i think that you've got to decide
for example i am so uncomfortably
convinced of how the v friends thing
plays out i can also die tonight
and then it doesn't
i mean it's just true it's just true
right so like if god willing
i can operate this thing for the next
but the ex but the problem is it's not
far enough along right so when i think
about v friends if i can do this for 15
years then i feel very comfortable then
it's marvel then it's disney then it's
established and operators can take it
not even anybody can take it bob iger is
not related to walt disney like you can
you know you can do things but i still
need at least 15 years to really set it
for at least like what's going through
my body as what this is gonna be
so i think the way you have to think
about it my friend is
what's the allocation like you know look
sitting on cash
versus investing it has been a proven
model over like and so
i think one needs to sit on enough cash
for a rainy day one should only invest
money that they can afford to go to zero
because you have to especially in
something as high risk as nfts we're not
talking about you investing in vayner
media stock where the ad industry has
been around for 100 years you still have
to be empathetic that obviously i
believe in it but it's too early but
i think that's the way you have to think
about that
but
as far as your part
i always tell people to do [ __ ] like
it's always the same thing one of my
favorite things that you've heard a
million times the reason i love saying
you can't read about push-ups is it's
just so easy to understand right like
yeah it's very hard to get the benefit
for some reason people think you can get
the benefit in other parts of their life
especially business like as if you just
can't
so like if it's comedy like make a
comedy skit go
and literally go to an open mic and try
to do stand-up like if you don't do you
don't know and you don't taste
right that's what was so big about you
tasting the tick-tock like that was out
of necessity that's why kovid during
coven more people took my advice than
any other time ever because they had no
other choice
you know right like during the other
time yeah
it's consistently been good
and i'll tell you why it's consistently
good because i only talk about [ __ ]
that's already happened
there's no guessing
and so i think that for you you've got
to
oh i would try to start doing all those
things i would like literally start
writing tomorrow i would
literally try to start doing comedy
either open mic or a piece of tic toc
comedy skit dm 100 people back to the i
emailed you gary email me a hundred
times like
dm 100 people that you think are good
because you might be improv more than
stand up well then that means you need
other people well there's a million of
those people on tick tock and instagram
making skits one of them might want to
do one with you you know and so
thank you you're welcome about my french
bulldogs
you know even that like i i also
something i'm very hot and i want to
triple down on it's talk about
back to books crush it
i just
wish people built more financial
infrastructure around the things they
actually like it works
so much more it's just too hard to build
like a career of meaning or a business
of meaning on something you don't like
if you're just doing it for the money
it's got no shot long term you could
make money plenty of people have but
like if you're gonna really do it and
enjoy it back to happiness like alien
inc like you got to do it around
something and so like maybe it's around
the french bulldogs like i really think
about that stuff
yeah of course
[Music]